hi everyone welcome welcome to the
second lecture on deep learning for CST
to 9 so a quick announcement before we
start there is a Piazza post number 695
which is the meet quarter survey for CST
to nine so fill it in when you have time
ok so let's get back to deep learning so
last week together we've seen what the
neural network is and we started by
defining the logistic regression from a
neural network perspective we said that
logistic regression can be viewed as a
one neuron neural network where there is
a linear part and an activation part
which was sigmoid in that case we we've
seen that sigmoid is a common activation
function to be used for classification
tasks because it casts a number between
minus infinity and plus infinity
0 in the z-row one interval which can be
interpreted as a probability and then we
introduced the neural network so we
started to stack some neurons inside a
layer and then stack layer on top of
each other
and we said that the more we stack
layers the more parameters we have and
the more parameters we have the more our
network is able to copy the complexity
of our data because it becomes more
flexible so we stopped at a point where
we did a forward propagation we had an
example during training before were
propagated through the network we get
the output then we compute the cost
function which compares this output to
the ground truth and we were in the
process of back propagating the error to
tell our parameters how they should move
in order to detect cuts more properly
does that make sense all this part so
today we're going to continue that so
we're in the second part neural networks
we're going to derive the back
propagation with the chain rule and
after that we're going to talk about how
to improve our neural networks because
in practice it's not because you
designed in your own network that is
going to work there's a lot of hacks and
tricks that you need to know in order to
make a neural network work ok let's go
so first thing that we talked about is
in order to define our optimization
problem and find our right parameters we
need to define a cost function and
usually we said we would use the letter
J to denote the cost function so here
when I talk about cost function I'm
talking about a batch of examples it
means I'm for propagating M examples at
a time you remember why we do that
what's the reason we use a batch instead
of a single example vectorization we
want to use what our GPU can do and
paralyze the computation so that's what
we do so we have M examples that go for
propagate in the network and each of
them has a loss function associated with
them the average of the loss functions
over the batch give us the cost function
and we had defined this loss function
together L of I assuming we're still and
just as a reminder we're still in this
network where where we had a cat
remember this 1 X 1 2 X n the cat was
flattened into a vector RGB matrix into
one vector and then there was a neural
network with three neurons then two
neurons than one neuron remember fully
connected here everything and then we
remember this one I think that what is
this one ok so now we're here we take M
images of cats or non cats for propagate
everything in the network compute a loss
function for each of them average it and
get the cost function so our last
function was the binary cross-entropy
or also called the loss function the
logistic loss function it was the
following y hi
log of y hat I plus 1 minus y I log
of 1 minus y hat bye
so let me circle this one it's an
important one and what we said is that
this network has many parameters and we
said the first layer has W 1 V 1 the
second layer has W 2 V 2 and the third
layer has W 3 B 3 where the square
brackets this denotes the layer and we
have to train all these parameters one
thing we noticed is that because we want
to make a good use of the chain rule
we're going to start by by computing the
derivative of these guys W 3 and V 3 and
then come back and do W 2 and V 2 and
then back again W 1 and B 1 in order to
use our formulas of the update of the
gradient descent where W would be equal
to W minus alpha derivative of the cost
with respect to W and this for any layer
L between 1 & 3 same for B
okay so let's try to do it this is the
first number we want to compute and
remember the reason we want to compute
derivative of the cost with respect to W
3 is because the relationship between W
3 and the cost is easier than the
relationship between W 1 and the cost
because W 1 had much more connection
going through the network before ending
up in the cost computation so one thing
we should not cease before starting this
calculation is that the derivative is
linear so this if I take the derivative
of J I can just take the derivative of L
and it's the same thing I just need to
add the summation prior to that because
derivative is a linear operation that
make sense to everyone so instead of
computing this I'm going to compute that
and then I will add the summation if we
just make our notation easier so I'm
taking the derivative of a loss of one
example propagated through the network
with respect to W 3 so let's do the
calculation together everyone I have a
minus y I derivative with respect to W 3
of what we remember that Y hat was equal
to Sigma of W 3x plus B or W 3 a 2 plus
B because a 2 is the input to the second
layer remember so I would write it down
here sigmoid of W 3 a 2 plus B 3 ok yeah
this is good like that it's too small W
through a 2 plus B 3 it's good like that
okay so we have this term and then we
have the second term which is plus 1
minus y I times derivative of w3 ability
with respect to W 3 of 1 oh sorry I
forgot the logarithm here of log of 1
minus Sigma of W 3 a 2 plus B 3 and so
just a reminder the reason we have this
is because we've written the forward
propagation in the previous class you
guys remember the four forward
propagation we had z3 which took a 2 as
input and computed the linear part and
sigmoid this is the activation function
used in the last neuron here okay so
let's try to to compute this derivative
Y I so the derivative of log log prime
equals 1 over log I'm ready this formula
so I will just take 1 over sorry 1 over
X minus 1 over X if you put your next
here so block prime of X so I will take
1 over sigmoid of w3 a 2 plus B 3 I know
that this thing can be written a 3 right
so I will just write a 3 instead of
writing the simulator game so we have 1
over a 3 times the derivative of a 3
with respect to W 3 remember is that I'm
gonna write it down here if we take the
derivative of sigmoid of blah blah blah
let's say derivative of log of sigmoid
over W what we have is 1 over the
sigmoid
time's the derivative with respect to w3
of the sigmoid does that make sense
that's what we're using here so the
derivative of sigmoid sigmoid prime of X
is actually pretty easy to compute is
sigmoid of x times 1 minus Sigma of X ok
so I'm just going to take the derivative
is going to give me 8 a 3 times 1 minus
a 3 there is still one step because
there is a composition of three
functions here there is a logarithm
there's a sigmoid and there's also a
linear function WX plus B or W a 2 plus
B so I also need to take the derivative
of the linear part with respect to W 3
because I know that sigmoid of W 3 a 2
plus B 3 if I want to take the
derivative of that with respect to W 3 I
need to go inside and take the
derivative of what's inside ok so this
will give me the sigmoid or whatever a 3
times 1 minus a 3 times the derivative
with respect to W 3 of the linear part
does this make sense so I'm going to
write it here bigger here I need to take
the derivative of the linear part with
respect to W 3 which is equal to a 2
transpose so one thing you you may want
to check is when we compute
when I'm trying to compute this
derivative I'm trying to compute this
derivative why is there a transpose that
comes out how do you come up with that
you look at the shape here what's the
shape of w3 someone remembers one by two
yeah
why one by two yeah it's connecting two
neurons to one your own so it has to be
one by two easily flip it and in order
to come back to that you can write your
forward propagation make the shape
analysis and find out that it's a one by
two matrix how about this thing what's
the shape of that hmm the scaler yeah so
scaler so it's one by one how do you
know is because this thing is basically
z3 is the linear part of the last neuron
and a3 we know that it's Y hat so it's a
scalar between zero and one so this has
to be a scalar as well because taking
the sigmoid should not change the shape
so now the question is what's the shape
of this entire thing the shape of this
entire thing should be the shape of w3
because you're taking the derivative of
a scalar with respect to a higher
dimensional matrix or vector here called
a row vector then it means that the
shape of this has to be the same shape
of w3 so 1 by 2 and you know that when
you take this simple derivative in in
real like in with scalars not with high
dimensional you know that this is an
easy derivative it just should it should
give you a 2 right but in higher
dimensions sometimes you have transposed
that come up and
you know that the answer is a to
transpose is because you know that a 2
is a 2 by 1 matrix so this is not
possible it's not possible to get a 2
because otherwise it wouldn't match the
derivative that you're calculating so it
has to be a 2 transpose so either you
you learn the formula by heart or you
you learn how to analyze shapes ok any
questions on that so that's why it's a 2
transpose now minus y I so I'm I'm on
this one now the second term of the of
the derivative and I take the derivative
of this so I get 1 over 1 minus a 3 a 3
denotes the sigmoid so I'm just copying
this back using the fact that the
derivative a logarithm is 1 over X and
then I will multiply this by the
derivative of 1 minus a 3 with respect
to W 3 I know that there's a minus that
needs to come up so I would write it
down here minus 1 and I also have the
derivative of the sigmoid with respect
to what's inside the sigmoid so a 3
times 1 minus a 3 and what's the last
term the last term is simply the one we
just talked about it's the derivative of
what's inside the sigmoid with respect
to W 3 so it's a 2 transpose again ok
so now I will just simplify I know this
scalar simplifies with this one this one
simplifies with that one really going to
copy back all the results - why I times
1 minus a 3 a 2 transpose plus 1 minus y
I times the - I'm going to put the minus
here so I'm taking the - putting it on
on the front times a 3 times a 2
transpose and then quickly looking at
that I see that some of the terms will
cancel out right okay so I have one term
here why why I time this - a 3 a 2
transpose would cancel out with + y i-83
a 2 transpose to make sense so like the
term that we multiply this number we
cancel out with the term we multiply
this number going to continue it gives
me Y I times a 2 transpose this part
minus a 3 times a 2 transpose I can
factor this because I have the same term
a 2 transpose and gives me finally why I
- a 3 times a 2 transpose okay so it
doesn't look that bad actually I don't
know when we take a derivative of
something kind of ugly we expect
something ugly to come out but this
doesn't seem too bad
any questions on that I let you write it
quickly and then we're going to move to
the rest so once I get this result I can
just write down the cost for derivative
with respect to W 3
I know it's just 1 - I just need to take
the summation of this thing so why I - a
3 times y 2 transpose a 2 transpose and
I have a minus sign coming up front so
that's my derivative okay so we were
done with that and we can we can just
take this formula plug it in back in our
gradient descent update rule and update
w3 yeah now the question is you can do
the same thing as as we just did but
with v3 is going to be the similar
difficulty we're going to do it with W -
now and think how does that back
propagate to W - so now it's W to stern
we want to compute derivative of L the
loss with respect to W of the second
layer the question is how I'm gonna get
this one without having too much work
I'm not going to start over here as we
said last time I'm going to use the
chain rule of calculus so I'm going to
try to decompose this derivative into
several derivatives so I know that Y hat
is the first thing that is connected to
the loss function right the output
neuron is directly connected to the last
function so I'm going to take the
derivative of the last function with
respect to Y hat also called a tree
right is the easiest one I can calculate
I also know that a tree which is the
output activation of the last neuron is
connected with the linear part of the
last neuron which is z3 so I can take
derivative of a tree with respect to Z 3
you remember what this is going to be
derivative of a tree with respect to Z
three derivative of sigmoid I know that
a tree called sigmoid of z 3 so this
derivative is very simple it's just that
it's just 8 3 times 1 minus a 3 right so
I'm going to continue I know that Z 3 Z
3 is equal to what it's equal to W 3 a 2
plus B which path things I need do I
need to take in order to back propagate
I don't want to take the derivative with
respect to W 3 because I went yet stuck
respect to B 3 because I will get stuck
I will take the derivative with respect
to a 2 because a 2 will be connected to
Z 2 Z 2 will be connected to a 1 and I
can back propagate from this path so I'm
going to take the relative of Z 3 with
respect to a 2 to have my error back
propagate and so on I know that a 2 is
equal to Sigma of Z 2 so I'm just going
to do that and I know that this
derivative is going to be easy as well
and finally I also know that Z 2 is
connected to W 2 so I'm going to take
derivative of Z 2 with respect to W 2 so
just what I want you to get is the
thought process of this chain rule why
don't we take a derivative with respect
to W 3 or B threes because we will get
stuck we want the error to back
propagate and in order for the error to
back propagate we have to go through
variables that are connected to each
other
does it make sense so now the question
is how can we use this how can we use
the derivative we already have in order
to to to to compute the derivative with
respect to W 2
can someone tell me how we can use the
results from this calculation in order
not to do it again
you cash it
so there's another discussion on caching
which is which is correct that's in
order to get this result very quickly we
will use cash but what I want here is to
you to tell me if this result appears
somewhere here
yeah the first three terms so this one
this one in this one yeah is it the
first two terms or the first three terms
the first two terms here but good
intuition yeah so these results is
actually the first two terms here we
just calculated it okay well how do we
know that it's not easy to see one thing
we know based on what we've written in
very big on this board is that the
derivative of z3 because this is III
right derivative of z3 with respect to W
3 is a 2 transpose right so I could
write here that this thing is the
relative of z3 with respect to W 3 is
correct so I know that because I wanted
to compute the derivative of the loss to
W 3 I know that I could have written
derivative of loss with respect to W 3
as derivative of loss with respect to Z
3 times derivative of z3 with respect to
W 3 correct and I know that this is a to
transpose so it means that this thing is
the receive of the loss with respect to
Z 3 does it make sense so I got I got my
decomposition of the derivative we had
if we wanted to use the chain rule from
here on we could have just separated it
into two terms and took the derivative
here okay so I know the result of this
thing I know that this thing is
basically 83 minus y times a 2 transpose
I just flipped it because of the minus
sign
okay now tell me what's disturb what is
it sir
let's go back yeah so sigmoid I'm just
going to write it a 2 times 1 minus a 2
if that makes sense
Sigma 8 times 1 minus Sigma what is this
term
oh sorry my bad that's not the right one
this one this one is that this one is
sigmoid a 2 is sigmoid of Z 2 so this
result comes from this term what's what
about this term sorry W 3 is it W 3 or
no I heard transpose how do we know if
it's W 3 or W 3 transpose so let's look
at the shape of this what's D 3 it's one
by one it's a scalar is the linear part
of the last neuron what's the shape of
that this is two one we have two neurons
in the layer W 3 we said that it was the
1 by 2 matrix so we have to transpose it
so the result of that is W 3 transpose
and how about the last term
same as here one layer before yeah
someone said day 1 transpose ok yep this
one there's a transpose here oh oh yeah
yeah you correct you correct thank you
that's what you mean
yeah this one was from the z3 dw3 we
didn't end up using that because we will
get stuck so there's no idea to
transpose here Thanks
any other questions or remarks so that's
cool let's write let's write down our
derivative cleanly on the board so we
have derivative of our last function
with respect to W 2 which seems to be
equal to a 3 minus y from the first term
the second term seems to be equal to W 3
transpose then we have a term which is a
2 times 1 minus a 2 ok and finally
finally we have another term that is a 1
transpose so are we done or not
so our triggers the thing is there's two
ways to compute derivatives either you
go very rigorously and do what we did
here for w2 or you try to do a chain
moon analysis and you try to fit the
terms the problem is this result is not
completely correct there is a shape
problem it means when we took our
derivatives which should have flipped
some of the terms we did it there is
actually we won't have time to go in the
details in this lecture because we have
other things to see but there is a
section note I think on the website
which details the other method which is
more rigorous which is like that for all
the derivatives what we're going to see
is how you can use chain rule plus shape
analysis to come up with the results
very quickly okay so let's let's analyze
the shape of all that we know that the
first term is a scalar into 1 by 1 we
know that the second term is the
transpose of 1 by 2 so it's 2 by 1 and
we know that this thing here a 2 times 1
minus a 2 is 2 by 1 it's an element-wise
product and this one is a 1 transpose so
it's 3 by 1 transpose so it's 1 by 3 so
there seem to be a problem here there is
no match between these two operations
for example right so the question is how
can we how can we put everything
together if we do it very good a city we
know how to put it together if you're
used to doing the chain rule
you can quickly quickly do it around so
after experience you will be able to to
fit all these together the important
thing to know is that here there is an
element twice product which is here so
every time you will take the derivative
of the sigmoid is going to end up being
an element twice product and it's the
case whatever the activation that you're
using is so the right result is this one
so here I have my elementwise product of
a 2 by 1 by a 2 by 1 so it gives me a 2
by 1 column vector and then I need
something that is 1 by 1 and 1 by 3 how
do I know what what do I need to have I
know that the shape of this thing w3
needs to be 2 by 3 it's connecting two
three neurons to neurons so w2 has to be
2 by 3 in order to end up with this I
know that this has to come here a3 minus
y and a1 transpose comes again and here
I get my correct answer
don't worry if it's the first time you
do the chain rule and is going quickly
don't worry read the lecture notes with
the rigorous parts taking the derivative
it will make more sense but I feel that
usually in practice we don't compute
these chain rules anymore because
because programming frameworks do it for
us
but it's important to know at least how
the chain will decomposes and also how
to make this the compute this derivative
if you read research papers specifically
any questions on that I think I want to
go back to what you mentioned with the
cache so why is cache very important
that was your question as well yeah yeah
it has to be so it means when you take
the derivative of Samoyed you take
derivative with respect to every entry
of the matrix which gives you an element
twice product going back to the cache so
one thing is it seems that during back
propagation there is a lot of terms that
appear that were computed during forward
propagation right all these terms a 1
transpose a 2 a 3 all these we have it
from the for propagation so if we don't
catch anything we have to recompute them
it means I'm going backwards but then I
feel oh I need a 2 actually so I have to
really go forward the game to get a 2 I
go backwards I need a 1 I need to
forward propagate my X again to get a 1
I don't want to do that so in order to
avoid that when I do my for propagation
I would keep in memory almost all the
values that I'm getting including the
W's because as you see to compute the
derivative of loss with respect W to we
need W 3 but also the activation or
linear variables so I'm going to save
them in my in my network during the for
propagation in order to use it during
the backward propagation that make sense
and again it's all for computation
efficiency it has some memory cost
okay so that was the backpropagation
and now I can use my formula of the cost
with respect to the last function and I
know that this is going to be my update
this is going to be used in order to
update w2 and I will do the same for w1
then you guys can do it at home if you
want to make sure you understood take
the derivative with respect to w1 okay
so let's move on to the next part which
is improving your neural network so in
practice when you when you do this
process of training for propagation
backward propagation updates you don't
end up having a good network most of the
time in order to get a good network you
need to improve it you need to use a
bunch of techniques that will make your
network work in practice
the first the first trick is to use
different activation functions so
together we've seen one activation
function which was sigmoid and we
remember the graph of sigmoid is getting
a number between minus infinity and plus
infinity and casting it between zero and
one and we know that the formula is
sigmoid of z equals 1 over 1 plus
exponential minus z we also know that
the derivative of sigmoid is sigmoid of
Z times 1 minus Sigma of Z okay another
very common activation function is relu
we talked quickly about it last time
value of Z which is equal to 0 if the
is less than zero and Z if Z is positive
so the graph of relu
looks like something like this with and
finally another one we were using
commonly as well is tan H so hyperbolic
tangent and tan H of Z equals
exponential Z minus exponential minus Z
over exponential Z plus exponential
minus Z the derivative of tan H is 1
minus tan H squared of Z and the graph
looks kind of like sigmoid but but it
goes between minus one and plus one so
one question now that I've given you
three activation function can you guess
why we would use one instead of the
other and and which one has more
benefits so when I talk about activation
functions I talk about the functions
that you will put in these neurons after
the linear parts what do you think is
the main advantage of sigmoid
yeah yeah you use it for classification
between it gives you a probability
what's the main disadvantage of sigmoid
it's easy that should be an advantage
should be a benefit yeah correct if
you're at high activation if you are
high Z's or low Z's your graduate is
very close to zero so look here based on
this graph we know that if Z is very big
if Z is very big our gradient is going
to be very small the slope of this graph
is very very small it's almost flat same
for these that are very low in the
negative right what's the problem with
having low gradients is when I'm back
propagating if the Zi clash was big the
gradient is going to be very small and
it would be super hard to update my
parameters that are early in the network
because the gradient is just going to
vanish does it make sense
so sigmoid is one of these activation
which which works very well in the
linear regime but has trouble working in
saturating regimes because the network
doesn't update the parameters properly
it goes very very slowly we're going to
talk about that a little more
how about tonnage very similar right
similar like high seas and low these
lead to saturation of a tannish
activation relu on the other hand
doesn't have this problem if Z is very
big in the positives there is no
saturation the gradient just passes and
the gradient is one when we're here
right the slope is equal to one so it's
actually just directing the gradient to
some entry it's not multiplying it by
anything when you back propagate so you
know this term here this term that I
have here all the a 3 minus 8 3 times 1
minus a 3 or a 2 1 times 1 minus a 2 if
we use real activations when we change
these
with what with with the derivative of r
lu and the derivative of r lu can be
written indicator function of z being
positive you've seen in indicator
functions so this is equal to 1 if Z is
positive 0 otherwise ok so we will see
why we use Rayleigh mostly yeah yeah
free you remember the house prediction
example in that case if you know if you
only predict the price of a house based
on some features you would use value
because you know that the output should
be a positive number between 0 and plus
infinity it doesn't make sense to use
one of 10 H or Samoyed yeah doesn't
really matter I think if if I want my
output to be between 0 and 1 I would use
Samoyed if I owned my output to be
between minus 1 and 1
I would use tonnage so you know there is
there are some tasks where the output is
kind of a reward or a minus reward that
you want to get like in reinforcement
learning you would use 10 H as an output
activation which is because minus 1
looks like a negative reward plus 1
looks like a positive reward and you
want to decide what should be the reward
good question why do we consider these
functions we can actually consider any
functions apart from the identity
function so let's see why
thanks for the transition like why do we
need activation functions so let's
assume that we have a network which is
the same as before so our network is
three neurons casting into two neurons
casting into one your own and we're
trying to use activations or equal to
identity functions so it means Z is
given to Z let's try to derive the for
propagation Y hat equals a tree equals Z
3 equals W 3 a 2 plus B 3 I know that a
2 a 2 is equal to Z 2 because there is
no activation and Z 2 is equal to W 2 A
1 plus B 2 so I can cast here W 2 W 2 A
1 plus B 2 plus B 3 I can continue I
know that a 1 is equal to Z 1 and I know
that Z 1 is w 1 X plus B
and B equals W three times W two times B
1 plus W 3 times B 2 plus B 3 so what's
the insight here is that we need
activation functions the reason is if
you don't use activation functions no
matter how deep is your network is going
to be equivalent to a linear regression
so the complexity of the network comes
from the activation function in the
reason we can understand if we're trying
to detect cuts what we're trying to do
is to train a network that will mimic
the formula of detecting cuts we don't
know this formula so we want to mimic it
using a lot of time matters if we just
have a linear regression we cannot mimic
this because we're going to look at
pixel by pixel and assign every way to a
certain pixel if I give a new example
it's not gonna work anymore yeah yeah so
I think that's that that goes back to
your question as well so this is why we
need activation functions and then the
question was can we use different
activation functions and how do we how
do we put them inside a layer or inside
neurons usually we would use there are
more activation functions I think in CS
2:30 we go over a few more but not not
not today these have been designed with
experience so these are the ones that
that that work better and let's our
networks train there are plenty of other
activation functions that have been
tested
usually you would you would use the same
activation functions inside every layer
so when you it's it's a it's it's for
training it doesn't have any special
reason I think but when you have a
network like that you would call this
layer a random layer meaning it's a
fully connected layer with radioactive
ation this one a sigmoid layer it means
it's a fully connected layer with the
sigmoid activation and the last one is
sigmoid I I think people have been
trying a lot of putting activate
different activations in different
neurons in a layer in different layers
and the consensus was using one
activation in the layer and also using
one of these three activations yeah so
if someone comes up with a better
activation that is obviously helping
training our models on different data
sets people would adopt it but right now
these are the ones that work better
you know last time we talked about hyper
parameters a little bit these are all
hyper parameters so in practice you're
not going to choose these randomly
you're going to try a bunch of them and
choose some of them that seem to help
your model train there's a lot of
experimental results in deep burning and
we don't really understand fully why
certain activations work better than
others okay let's move on
okay let's go over initialization
techniques
okay
let me use this port so another trick
that you can use in order to help your
network train our initialization methods
and normalization methods so earlier we
talked about the fact that if Z is too
big or Z is too low in the negative
numbers
it will lead to saturation of the
network so in order to avoid that you
can use normalization of the input so
assume that you have a network where the
data is 2-dimensional x1 x2 is your
two-dimensional input you can assume
that x1 x2 is distributed like this
thing so this is if I plot X 1 again X 2
for a lot of data I will get that type
of graph the problem is if I do my W X
plus B to compute my Z 1 if x's are very
big it will lead to very big Z's which
will lead to saturated activations in
order to avoid that one method is to
compute the mean of this data using mu
equals 1 over the size of the batch of
the internet you have in the training
set sum of excise so you're just giving
you the mean for x1 and the mean for x2
you would compute the operation x equals
x minus mu and you will get that type of
plot if you re plot the transform data
let's say X 1 tilde X 2 tilde so here
it's a little better but it's still not
good in order to solve the problem fully
you're going to compute Sigma squared
which is basically the standard
deviation squared so the variance of the
data and then you will divide by Sigma
square
so you would do that and you would make
the transformation of X being equal to X
divided by Sigma and it will give you a
graph that is centered up so you usually
prefer to to work with a centered data
yeah sorry oh yeah yeah sorry sorry yeah
great so if we subtract the mean of X 1
and X 2 so it should look like this but
be centered okay and then if you says if
you standardize it it looks like
something like that so why is it better
because if you look at your your your
loss function now before the loss
function would look like something like
this
and after normalizing the input it may
look like something something like this
so what's the difference between these
two loss functions why is this one
easier to Train is because if you have a
starting point that is here let's say
your gradient descent algorithm is going
to go to towards approximately the
steepest slope so you're going to go
there and then this one is going to go
there and then you're going to go there
and then you're going to go there like
that and so on until you end up at the
right point but the steepest slope in
this loss contour is always pointing
towards the middle so if you start
somewhere you will directly go towards
the minimum of your loss function so
that's why it's helpful usually to
normalize so this is one method and in
practice the way you initialize your
weights is very important yeah
yes so exactly so here I used a very
simple case but you would divide
element-wise by the Sigma here okay so
like every entry of your matrix you
would divide it by the Sigma or one
other thing that is important to notice
this Sigma and mu are computed over the
training set you have a training set you
compute the mean of the training set the
standard deviation of the training set
and these Sigma and you have to be used
on the test set as well it means now
that you want to test your algorithm on
the test set you should not compute the
mean of the test set and the standard
deviation of the test set and normalize
your test input through the network
instead you should use the mu and the
Sigma that were completed on the train
set because your network is used to see
this type of transformation as an input
so you want the distribution of the
input at the first year to be always the
same no matter if it's the train or the
test set
here likely this leads to fewer
iterations okay we have a lot to see so
I will I will skip a few questions so
let's let's delve a little more into
vanishing and exploding radius so in
order to get an intuition of why we have
this vanishing or exploding Radian
problem we can consider a network which
is very very deep and has a two
dimensional input okay and so on so
let's say we have let's say we have ten
layers in total 10 layers plus an output
layer so assume assume all the
activations all the activations are
identity functions and assume that these
biases are equal to 0 if you compute Y
hats the output of the network with
respect to the input you know that Y hat
would be equal to W of layer L capital L
denotes the last layer times a L minus 1
plus BL but be L is 0 so we can remove
it WL x al minus 1 you know that al
minus 1 is W l minus 1 times a L minus 2
because the activation is an identity
function and so on you can back
propagate can go back and you will get
that Y hat equals W L times W L minus 1
times blah blah blah times w1 times X
you get something like that right so now
let's let's consider two cases let's
consider where the case where the WL
matrices are a little bigger than the
identity function a little larger than
the islands function in terms of values
let's say WL including all these so all
these matrices which are two by two
matrices right are these ones what's the
consequence the consequence is that this
whole thing here is going to be equal to
one point five to the power L one point
five to the power L zero zero it will it
will make Y hat explode to make the
value of y hat explode just because this
number is a tiny little bit more than
one same phenomena if we had zero point
five instead of one point five here the
value the multiplicative value of all
these matrices will be zero point five
to the power L here 0.5 to the power L
here and Y hat will always be very close
to zero so you see the issue with
vanishing exploding gradient is that all
the Earth's add up like multiplied each
other and if you end up with numbers
that are smaller than 1 you will get
totally vanished gradient when you go
back if you have values that are a
little bigger than 1 you will get
exploding gradient so we did it as a
forward propagation equation we could
have done it exactly the same analysis
with the derivatives assuming the
derivatives of the weight matrices are a
little lower than the identity or a
little higher than the identity so we
want to avoid that one way that is not
perfect to avoid this is to initialize
your weight properly initialize them
into the right range of values so you
agree that we would prefer the weights
to be around 1 as close as possible to 1
if they're very close to 1 we probably
we can avoid the vanishing and exploding
radiant problem so let's look at the
initialization problem the first thing
to look at is example of the 1 euro if
you consider this neuron here which has
a bunch of inputs and outputs on
activation a you know that the equation
inside the neuron is a equals whatever
function let's say sigmoid of Z and you
know that Z is equal to W 1 X 1 plus W 2
X 2 plus blah blah blah plus W and X n
so it's a dot product between the W's
and the X's so the interesting thing to
notice is that we have n terms here so
in order for Z to not explode we would
like all of this term to be small if W
is are too big then this term will
explode with the size of the input of
the layer so instead if we have a large
n means the input is very large what we
want is very small w i's so the larger n
the smaller has to be W I so based on
this intuition it seems that it would be
a good idea to initialize w i's with
something that is close to 1 over n we
have n terms the more terms we have the
more likely z is going to be big but if
our initialization says the more terms
you have the smaller the value of the
weights we should be able to keep Zener
in a certain range that is appropriate
to avoid vanishing and exploding
gradients so this term to be a possible
initialization scheme
so in practice I'm going to write a few
initial ization schemes that we're not
going to prove if you interested in
seeing more proofs of that you can take
CS 2:30 where we prove this
initialization scheme I take down the
board
so there are a few initialization that
are commonly used and again this is this
is very practical and people have been
testing a lot of initializations but
they ended up using those so one is to
initialize the weights I'm writing the
code for those of you who know one on PI
not going to compile it here with
whatever shape you're using element
twice times the square root of one over
N of L minus one so what does that mean
it means that I will look at the number
of input I'm writing an n L minus one
here and to the L minus one I'm looking
at how many inputs are coming to my
layer assuming we're at layer L how many
inputs are coming I'm going to
initialize the weights of this layer
proportionally to the number of inputs
that are coming in so the intuition is
very similar to what we described there
so this initialization has been shown to
work very well for sigmoid activation so
if you use sigmoid what's interesting is
if you use relu it's been it's been
observed that putting a two here instead
of a one would make the network train
better and again it's very practical
it's one of the fields that that we need
more Theory on it but a lot of
observation has been made so far you
guys want to do that as a project to see
why it is happening it would be
interested okay and finally there is a
more common one that is used which is
called Xavier initialization which which
proposes to update the weights
using square root of 1 over an L minus 1
for 10h this is another one and another
one that is I believe called slow
initialization recommends to to
initialize the weights of a layer using
the foreign formula so quickly the quick
intuition behind the last one the last
one is very often used the quick
intuition is that we're doing the same
thing but also for the back propagated
gradients so we're saying the weights
are going to multiply the back
propagated gradient so we also need to
look at how many inputs do we have
during the back propagation and L is the
number of inputs you have during back
propagation and L minus 1 is the number
of inputs you have during for
propagation so taking an average a
geometric average of those
and the reason we have a random function
here is because if you don't initialize
your weights randomly you will end up
with some problem called the symmetry
problem where every neuron is going to
learn kind of the same thing to avoid
that you will make the neuron starts at
different places and let them evolve
independently from each other as much as
possible so now we have two choices
either we go over regularization or
optimization how much have you talked
about regularization so far l1 l2 early
stopping all that's really stopping
everybody remembers well it is know a
little bit so let's go over optimization
I guess and then we will do some
regularization depending on the time we
have so I believe so far you've seen
gradient descent and stochastic gradient
descent as to possible optimization
algorithm in practice there is a
trade-off between these two which is
called mini-batch gradient descent what
is the trade-off the trade-off is that
batch gradient descent is cool because
you can use vectorization you can give a
batch of input for propagated all at
once during vac using a vectorized code
stochastic gradient descent advantage is
that the updates are very quick and
imagine that you have the data set with
1 million images 1 million images in the
data set and you want to do batch
gradient descent you know how long it's
going to take to do one updates very
long so we don't want that because maybe
we don't need to go over the full
dataset in order to have a good update
maybe the updates based on a thousand
examples might already give us the right
direction for the gradient of where to
go it's not going to be as good as on a
minyan example where is going to be a
very good approximation so that's why
most people would use mini-batch
gradient descent where you have a
trade-off between stochasticity and also
vectorization so in terms of notation
I'm going to call X the matrix X 1 X 2 X
m and capital y the same matrix with
wise so we have M training examples and
I'm going to split these into batches so
I'm going to call the first batch X 1
like this until X maybe T like that and
X 1 can contain probably X 1 until X
1,000 assuming it's a batch of a
thousand examples X 2 then will contain
X 1000 and one until X 2000 and so on so
this is the notation for the batch when
I use curly brackets same for y
so in terms of algorithm how does the
mini-batch gradient descent algorithm
work we're going to iterate so for TNT
from 1 to blah blah blah - how many
iteration you want to do we're going to
select a batch select a batch of XK 1 XT
YT you will forward propagate the batch
and you will back propagate the batch so
by forward propagation I mean you send
all the batch to the network and you
compute the lost functions for every
examples of the batch you sum them
together and you compute the cost
function over the entire batch which is
the average of the loss functions and so
assuming assuming the batch is of size
1,000 this will be the the formula to
compute the batch over 1,000 examples
and after the back propagation of course
update W L and the L for all the else
for all the layers this is the equation
so in terms of graph what you're likely
to see is that for batch gradient
descent your cost function J would have
looked like that
if you plot it against the number of
iterations on the other hand if you use
a mini batch gradient descent you're
most likely to see something like this
so it's also decreasing as a trend but
because the gradient is approximated and
doesn't necessarily go straight to the
to the middle of your last to the lower
point of the last function you will see
a kind of graph like that the smaller
the batch the more stochasticity so the
more noise you will have on your cost
function graph and of course if you if
we plot again if we plot the last
function and this was gradient descent
so this is the top view of the last
function assuming we're in two
dimensions your stochastic gradient
descent or batch gradient descent would
do something like that so the difference
is there seem to be less iteration with
the red algorithm but the iteration are
much heavier to compute so each of the
green iteration are going to be very
very very quick while the red ones are
going to be slow to compute this is the
trade off now there is another algorithm
that I want to go over which is called
the momentum momentum algorithm
sometimes called gradient descent plus
momentum algorithm so what's the
intuition behind momentum
the intuition is let's look at this lost
contour plot and I'm doing an extreme
case just to illustrate the intuition
assume you have a loss that is very
extended in one direction so this
direction is very extended and the other
one is smaller you're starting at the
points like this one your gradient
descent algorithm itself is going to
follow the following map it's going to
be orthogonal to the current contour is
au term contour loss is going to go
there and then there and then there and
then there and so on so what you would
like is to move a faster on the
horizontal line and slower to the
vertical on the vertical side so on this
axis you would like to move with smaller
updates and on this axis you want to
move with larger objects correct if this
happened we would probably end up in the
minimum much quicker than we currently
are so in order to do that we're going
to use a technique called momentum which
is going to look at the past gradients
so look at the past updates assume we're
here assume we're somewhere here
gradient descent doesn't look at its
past at all it just will compute the
fault propagation compute the backdrop
look at the direction and go to that
direction
what momentum is going to say is look at
the past updates that you did and try to
consider this past update in order to
find the right way to go so if you look
at the past update and you take an
average of the past update you would
take an average of this update going up
and the update after it going down the
average on the vertical side is going to
be small because one went up one went
down but on the horizontal axis both
went to the same direction so the update
will not change too much on the verts on
this axis so you're most likely to do
something like that if you use momentum
does it make sense the intuition behind
it so that's the intuition why we want
to use mind and for those of you who do
physics sometimes you can think of
momentum as friction you know like like
if you if you launch a rocket and you
want to move it quickly around it's not
gonna move because the rocket has a
certain weight and has a certain
momentum you cannot change its direction
very very noisily so let's see at the
implementation of of momentum gradient
descent oh and I believe we're almost
done right yeah okay so let's look at it
in the implementation quickly so
gradient descent was W equals W minus
alpha derivative of the loss with
respect to W what we're going to do is
we're going to use another variable
called velocity which is going to be the
average of the previous velocity and the
current weight update so we're going to
use that and instead of the updates
being the derivative directly we're
going to update the velocity so the
velocity is going to be a variable that
tracks the direction that we should take
regarding the current update and also
the past updates with a factor beta that
is B going to be the weight the
interesting point is that in terms of
implementation it's one more line of
code in terms of memory is just one
additional variable and it actually has
a big impact on the optimization there
are much more optimization algorithms
that we're not going to see together
today in C su-30 we teach something
called rmsprop
and Adam that's our
likely the the the ones that are used
the most in deep learning and the reason
is if you come up with an optimization
algorithm you still have to prove that
it works very well on a wide variety of
application between bv4 researchers
adopted for their research so Adam
brings momentum to the OP the returning
optimization algorithms okay thanks guys
and that's all for deep learning in cs2
tonight so far